it is one of the biggest climate threats
that the uk
faces and new research has found that
flooding also has a direct impact
on our health in pentra in shropshire
this house has been marooned three times
in 11 months
it's taken its toll on its owner it's
physically hard work it's utterly
exhausting
if one knows that the water is coming
you lift everything and i did this year
um in the days before the flood i got
all my furniture on trestles i
almost everything was safe from the
water but then it goes
and i'm left with a lot of muck in the
house a lot of damage to the house
and i'm physically drained the report
found that around 1.8 million people in
the uk
are living in areas at significant risk
of flooding
that number could increase to 2.6
million
in as little as 17 years and flood
victims are four
times more likely to suffer mental
health problems
than those unaffected by flooding
when it comes to extreme hot weather
researchers said in 2018
a series of heat waves made more likely
by
climate change led to eight and a half
thousand deaths
but they say something can be done we
need to tackle climate change
um the kind of root cause of it and and
we need to do that
by decarbonizing our economy making sure
that our homes are greener our transport
sector is greener
and actually that brings with it lots of
co-benefits so we know that
um people who walk and cycle more are
healthier um
you know and less of a burden on the nhs
um but also
that that brings with it benefits in
terms of cleaner air that
that helps people um right across the
country last year was the hottest on
record
and it's estimated that 12 million
people in the uk
will be vulnerable to heat waves in
future
researchers say the sooner we can
achieve a cleaner
greener world the better it will be for
our health
lisa dale sky news